[Music]
[Applause]
he's our good buddy ross tucker former
nfl offensive lineman great appearance
last week by the way ross will be
handling the afc title game duties
duties uh that'll be at arrowhead well
that's not the afc title game
fritzy
it's the division
title game oh oh yes
oh that's a covid related mistake but i
could i blame it on wait
you're blaming it on coven i think i may
have to call it a little brain fog have
you had covent for a decade
i think it would be the nfc divisional
playoff it's the amc it's you even
screwed that up
it's not the nfc
it he's he's covering the bills
and the chiefs
i need a nap or something it's the afc
divisional play-up thing i put title
game there yes ross will be handling the
afc titans
yeah let's bring in ross tucker clean up
the mess here if you can ron you're
going to be covering the chief's bills
at arrowhead
this weekend right
no i'm not
that's that's what makes this even
better i'm i'm in the uh i'm in the
booth in tampa i i got the rams and the
bucks it's the nfc divisional round i
mean i've said the wrong fritzy about
that twice i emailed him three times i
even told him that this story that i'm
i'm in the booth and mike golick
as seniors on the sideline
which is so cool for me dan cause i grew
up outside of philly and literally uh
when golic was playing for the eagles
they came to kutztown university and did
like a charity basketball game or
something
so i was in fifth grade it's like 1990.
i get there super early with my buddy
and i don't know who was handling it was
clyde simmons
uh mike golick andre waters and whoever
their handler was looked at me and my
buddy and said hey we need ball boys you
guys want to be our ball boys we were
like heck yeah so we were in the locker
room meanwhile they started to get so
tired during the game playing against
these teachers they actually put us in
the game and i drained two shots in
front of like 5 000 people so anyway
long story but i got golic's autograph
he was awesome that day i was 11 years
old and now i'll be part of a broadcast
with him even though fritzy got it wrong
three different ways i'll be part of a
broadcast with him on sunday okay that's
a nice story but let me go back to todd
you couldn't have whipped any more than
you did it it's the nfc it's not a title
game and i think i've been i think i've
been set up to my credits i have an
email that i phone to the guys that have
something very different than what you
just read okay something was printed
from an old one-sheet email
okay
i'm very upset actually about this
because i
thought it was on me
yeah i have physical evidence to show
what i sent was actually buck's
divisional player all right thank you by
the way dan
you also threw me a loop at the start of
the segment
because you came back from break and you
said hall of famer or not a hall of
famer i was like oh man i got very
excited obviously not as a player i
thought you meant like hall of fame
guest or not hall of fame media guy like
i got very excited and i realized it was
not actually about me well you had a
great appearance last week when you
mentioned that you basically uh urinated
uh during every game late in the game
that you'd sit on a towel
and uh what was the fallout from your
urination story last week
well uh one piece first of all people
loved it i had several of my buddies
around here in pennsylvania text me like
uh you peel your pants uh-huh like you
know ha ha ha
but dan monday night okay i'm on the
sideline
for rams cardinals and i had a back
surgery in buffalo so so people know the
worst thing about being a sideline
reporter
is just standing there for four hours
like it's terrible for your back so
during one of the tv timeouts i sit down
on like these luxury boxes the rams have
where you can't actually see the field
it's like below field level i don't know
who pays for these things but i'm
sitting there by the way paul george and
kawhi leonard are there an equipment guy
with all the nfl stuff on the cardinal
sideline comes over to me dan with one
of those gatorade towels
and he hands it to me i'm like
did i i'm good like did i do something
wrong he's like no i saw you on dan
patrick this week i didn't know if you
needed this or not
i was like no
no i'm good i don't hydrate as much as i
did when i was a player but literally
one of the cardinals equipment guys came
over to me with a gatorade towel because
they heard me with you last week that's
great we're talking to ross tucker i
still think he's working the rams and
the buccaneers coming up this weekend in
tampa uh loudest stadium
to you is where
so when i played um it was to me it was
the rca dome
in terms of indoor that place was so
loud i guess maybe they might have been
pumping in noise i don't know but that
place you couldn't even hear yourself
think so that's the cause the loudest
outdoor place
was arrowhead for sure now seattle's
very loud too
but arrowhead and this is actually
something dan i've never quite
understood you know how there's been so
many new stadiums recently
you know the giants got one and
obviously san francisco got one i don't
understand
why these franchises don't mimic
the acoustics
of seattle or kansas city it's not like
the pacific northwest or the midwest
people are louder than the northeast
people or whatever
i think they're so concerned with
maximizing revenue
and club space and suites
they don't they don't
mimic
the same acoustics that's a big
advantage man it's honestly dan if the
bills were playing the chiefs in buffalo
i would pick the bills because that
place was loud saturday night i was
there those people were going crazy
but it's in kansas city
takes away the offense's ability to have
the snap count advantage they'll have to
go silent so eileen kansas it makes a
big difference
yeah i i was wondering about that too
that there are certain stadiums that
there is a true in that seattle stadium
i mean that that's that's loud that and
that almost hurts your ears um i
remember being in the rca dome but i was
there for the super bowl so it was a
different ambiance there i've been to
lambo that that's a great field but
that's a home field advantage for
a variety of reasons there
you have the game with the rams going
into tampa
and i was
it feels like this is the rams game for
the taking
with the offensive line not healthy with
the buccaneers you don't have godwin in
there you don't have antonio brown
but it's hard to bet against tom brady
who do you think wins this game
totally agree with everything you just
said uh the rams are a healthier team
they've got cam akers back six months
after his achilles tear which is
incredible he looked good monday night
uh they won the battle up front against
the cardinals both sides the ball and
you're right i mean jensen's limping
around
i i personally don't think tristan worf
is going to be able to play
and even his backup josh wells has a
quad injury ryan carrigan got two sacks
on them last week now von miller who's
got six sacks in his last five games
this game is there for the rams taking
this is a game that they should win
but honestly dan i think it's gonna be a
close game
i think it's going to be a field goal
game in the fourth quarter and i can't
verbally do it like i i can't say
matthew stafford's going to beat tom
brady in a close playoff game
in the fourth quarter i will believe it
when i see it he's more likely to make a
critical error brady's more likely to
get the game winning points so i'll lean
brady there but i do think stafford
probably has the most to gain
of any quarterback this weekend you know
we would feel a lot differently
about matthew stafford if he gets the
rams to a conference championship game
if he wins two playoff games if he beats
tom brady on the road in the playoff
game i think he has probably more to
gain than anybody else this weekend yeah
that was my next question because
we know who has the most to lose and it
feels like that's aaron rodgers yes
would you say that fair
no question it's aaron rodgers and i'll
go a step further it's the green bay
packers organization
if if they lose
i don't see any way that aaron rodgers
goes back there i think he's just going
to think it's just not going to happen
for me here i'm going to move on
if they go to the super bowl or win it i
think there's a much greater likelihood
that rogers comes back i think this game
tomorrow night is that important for the
packers franchise
and you have the jimmy garoppolo
situation where it feels like he's
auditioning for his next job a win at
lambeau would be huge for him
i mentioned that joe burrow
if they would beat the titans
just elevating him and his status as a
top 10 top 8 quarterback in the nfl
ryan tannehill's probably not going to
get any credit if they win that game
right
probably not no you're right you're
right i mean they could get to the
conference championship tannehill i
think at this point probably has to get
to a super bowl and i would say the
titans they are they might be the
quietest
least respected number one seed
i can remember in a long time and i i
said this on twitter at ross tucker nfl
a couple weeks ago
i think they're one of the worst number
one seeds we've seen i mean you look at
the point spread you look at what the
vegas folks would say
they're one of the worst number one
seeds we've seen in a long time but
guess what they win two home games
they're going to the super bowl yeah
ross tucker host of the ross tucker
football podcast the color analyst in
the booth for the rams buccaneers with
dave pasch and mike golick senior coming
up sunday on westwood one how did we do
with that good
that was correct yes and by the way i
don't know if you know this dan
the bucks might have
the best press box food in the nfl
they have they have multiple carving
stations they serve bananas foster at
halftime so
i mentioned how important saturday night
is for the packers organization the bucs
organization has the opportunity to end
the year
number one in the ross tucker press box
food power rankings which is probably as
significant as anything that will happen
this weekend wow
that's a bold statement there huge huge
yeah uh
the road team that has the best chance
to win
is
buffalo bills
i think it's the bills okay i think they
might be the best team right now i mean
their defense is playing lights out josh
allen is incredible you know i think we
all know what they did saturday night
dan they did that against bill belichick
i mean they had a perfect game
against a bill belichick coached defense
seven touchdowns and a kneel down
it's incredibly impressive
uh that said even if they win this game
they still need to win one more likely
at tennessee to get to the super bowl
which i think they need to do to kind of
take that next step but i think the
bills have a great chance that game is
going to be incredible look i'm i'm
loving the rams bucks game i'm going to
be calling but i really do think bill's
chiefs is the game of the weekend
because i think more than any other game
i do believe the winner of bill's chiefs
is going to the super bowl sorry titans
fans you can be mad at me again but i
think winner of bill's chiefs is going
to super bowl i was also curious since
you did play offensive line and you also
played center for a little while the the
last
seconds of the cowboys game against the
49ers and the role that the center plays
on that play
uh where where do you stand on the
cowboys trying to pull that off and then
spotting the football
yeah so first of all i understand the
logic of what they were trying to do
you know they wanted to get it dan so
that they could throw a strike into the
end zone as opposed to a lob right as
opposed to a hail mary they wanted to
get close enough sort of like that
fourth and 21 touchdown pass justin
herbert threw in week 18 against the
raiders they wanted dak to be able to
put a line drive into the end zone gives
them more of a chance so i get that
we were always taught in those
situations
it's 16 seconds so whether it's enough
time to spike or enough time for a fast
field goal when it's fourth down you
don't have an opportunity to spike it
you gotta run on the field 16 seconds
is the number we were always given mike
mccarthy says it was 13 seconds the
problem i have with what mike mccarthy
said
is he said we practice it every week go
back and watch the tape noah brown the
receiver just kind of standing around
what you do is you have two choices
right you personally hand the ball to
the umpire or you hand the ball to the
center
who puts it down so everybody knows
where to line up and then the umpire has
to touch it release it so you can snap
it real quick they really didn't do
either one of those to me
the problem with them cutting it so
close they didn't allow for any
variables
i mean what if one of the d-linemen
accidentally kicked the ball london
fletcher used to do that all the time
you know it takes a couple seconds off
or what if they were smart enough to lay
on top of dak for a second or two
there's just a million things that could
go wrong like it did to not be able to
get the ball off which i thought they
cut it way too close yeah i don't think
they practice that every week or if they
do they didn't practice it correctly
because they they the margin of error
was so so small and you can't leave
like
you kind of exposed yourself as to this
the clock could run out on this play
instead of saying to dak
only get x number of yards if you're
gonna do it because they had two plays
called they had a pass play and then i
think dak changed at the line of
scrimmage and then took off well
they're letting you run for a reason
because you have no timeouts and the
clock is running that's what i didn't
understand you have to have a clock in
your head that says i have x number of
yards x number of seconds now i need to
get down and
i i just uh i there's no way they
practice that play every week and you
know what dan my bigger issue
to be honest with you was after the game
both mccarthy and dak prescott
complained about the officials now i
know dak came out
and apologized for saying good for the
fans for throwing stuff at the refs
which by the way was a good move by dak
but they still both
complained about the refs
and i think the older i get
the more i realize these teams seem to
be a reflection of ownership like the
the lack of
accountability and responsibility
mccarthy says i thought they would let
him play a little bit more what what
play is he talking about when randy
gregory just tackles the o lyman for no
reason when uh a diggy zuwa pulls down
alex mack when gallimore had his hands
up in like they were all legitimate
penalties dan like most of them were
pretty street snap they were all legit
penalties so rather than after the game
saying we need to do better with the
penalties there's too many they
complained about the refs so them
passing the buck rather than showing the
accountability and responsibility it's
why they have so many penalties in the
first place they're not disciplined they
don't take accountability for their
actions instead they blame others and
it's why the cowboys i feel like are the
same team every year
thank you ross we'll be uh we'll be
listening this weekend the bucks with
dave pasch and mike golick rams
buccaneers on westwood one and also you
can check him out on social media at
ross tucker nfl thank you buddy safe
travels absolutely thank you dan we'll
take a break play the days up next